a pawn in the corner but um nakamura
he does whoa or he goes oh
is it a blunder a huge blunder and you
see it on his face immediately
magnus carlsen he bluffed he tricked
nakamura he saw it immediately
nakamura's
just lost a rook and trajan horse yeah
he
he lulled in into a false sense of
security that bishop move it looked like
he was blocking his rook
um we'll go into detail a bit later on
but nakamura he's
just blundered he's lost immediately
he's going to lose a rook now and
oh that was a sneaky sneaky shot he uh
he did the classic thing when you know
your opponent is impatient
you offer them a shortcut
and it's just a trick so basically
magnus forced
this blunder well he didn't force it he
just
kind of it looked clumsy this bishop
retreating to the square i didn't like
it
david didn't like it i didn't even dream
about hikaru's move i didn't look that
deeply into the position
and uh i didn't see it at all karu
thought magnus blundered but magnus was
setting this trap he was saying okay you
go for this it looks like i'm losing but
no
um but it looks like so magnus is
shaking his head looks like he's
disappointed
is he just shocked that that move
actually happened
uh he's shocked that nakamura fell into
his trap i think um
yeah nakamura resigns
he resigns immediately here yeah we'll
have to consider